dès le début de la seconde guerre
mondiale le junker ce gie ou 87 et est
devenue l'une des armes les plus
redoutables de l'arsenal nazis
et ils participer en masse aux premiers
bombardements orchestrée par hitler et
elle est être considéré pour leur
efficacité dévastatrices comme un
instrument de victoires imparable
durant les neuf premiers mois de la
guerre leur bruit si caractéristique
terroriser les populations civiles alors
qu'ils paralysaient les armes et
d'europe de l'ouest
fiable et facile à entretenir sur le
front sa grande résistance aux tirs
défensif et son aptitude à rentrer au
bercail malgré le sérieux dégâts en
faisait l'un des appareils préférés des
pilotes nazis
grâce à un enchaînement quasi constant
de triomphe le choucas était devenu un
appareil mythique pour les uns et
redouté pour les autres
même s'il ne fut pas et de loin
l'appareil le plus produit de la seconde
guerre mondiale c'est celui qui aura
servi le plus longtemps
l'un des pionniers se cachant derrière
le choix du tout métal en aéronautique
et et hugo junkers à l'ingénieur
allemand
il déposa le brevet d'une technique qui
allait lui permettre de trouver une
parade dès 1915 au bois et toile c'était
le young heart j 1 équipé d'un moteur
mercedes
c'est donc sur ce biplan blindé de
soutien et de reconnaissance que fut
utilisé pour la première fois un
habillage en étal lors de la première
guerre mondiale
une poignée d'avionneur suivirent
l'exemple et construisirent selon le
même procédé une série d'avions
d'attaqué au sol et deux chasseurs
en octobre 1917 anthony fokker se joint
à gogo young hearts pour fonder la
société juncker fokker
deux ans plus tard elle était rebaptisé
juncker fluxus vers que
l'armistice venait d'être signé et
l'allemagne à accepter le traité lui
interdisant de développer son armement
l'affirmé juncker se concentre donc
exclusivement à l'aviation civile et
privés
en 1921 le vent en poupe elle dévoilait
son premier avion de ligne
en cinq ans grâce à ces appareils une
compagnie aérienne allait connaître ses
débuts la lufthansa
durant toutes les années 20 tous les
avions de lignes de transport construit
par juncker était exclusivement en métal
cette habitude était devenue la carte
d'identité de la société qui parachevait
son oeuvre en dévoilant un appareil au
succès extraordinaire le gie ou 52
mais si l'aviation civile assurer les
beaux jours de la firme google junkers
s'intéressait toujours en parallèle au
développement de l'aviation militaire
il détourna le traité signé entre
l'allemagne et les algues et en
établissant des succursales dans les
pays voisins
en 1928 l'une d'entre elles la ab flag
industry basé en suède produit d'un
monoplan biplace le cac 40 7
il était spécialement adapté aux
compliqué une technique qui allait
devenir la grande spécialité du ch tout
cas en 1933 après que l'allemagne ait
repris son effort de guerre et sous
l'égide de m houde est un as de la
première guerre mondiale le ministère de
l'air annonce son intention de
développer à bombardier destiné aux
attaques en piqué des démonstrations
impressionnantes effectué par un
appareil de l'aéronavale américaine
avait convaincu ou dote de l'efficacité
de cette méthode
en se basant sur le travail réalisé sur
le cac 40 7 juncker se met à l'ouvragé
pour produire son nouvel appareil
désigné gilles eu 87
le prototype fit son premier vol d'essai
en 1935 mais il s'écrase à au cours d'un
piqué tuant sur le coup son pilote et
son observateur
l'achitecture de cet appareil reposait
sur deux sections de fuselage
longitudinal
une fois en l'air sa voilure en w et son
train principal fixe lui conférait une
allure faussement nonchalante
au sol et donne l'impression d'être
massif alors qu'ils ne mesurent que onze
mètres de large et 14 d'envergure
à l'altitude de 4000 m son moteur humo
de 600 chevaux lui offrait une vitesse
maximale de 320 kilomètres heure
un énorme radiateur monté sous le nez en
charge le refroidissement du moteur
relié à une hélice trois pales à pas
variable
d'imposants aérofreins réduisait la
vitesse en piqué à 600 kilomètres heure
une verrière renforcée par de nombreux
montant recouvre les places des deux
membres d'équipage leur offrant un champ
de vision respectable
afin d'éviter que la bombe ne touche les
lys on utilisait un bras articulé pour
l'éloigner de l'appareil au moment du
largage
fin 1936 l'usiné junker de dessau
tournait à plein régime
le ministère de l'air avait effectué une
commande initiale de 250 appareils qui
furent livrés mettre à feu au printemps
la première unité à être doté de chtouka
a été le premier groupe 'on de chtouka
schwaller 162 surnommé himmelmann
certaines machines ont été envoyées en
espagne pour subir leur baptême du feu
au sein de la légion condor
cette division avait déjà acquis la
supériorité aérienne mais l'egypte 87
allait s'avérer cruciaux dans un grand
nombre d'offensives
il ils pilonnèrent madrid et devenir
redoutable quand leurs attaques et est
synchronisé avec un assaut terrestre
il était tout aussi efficace contre des
cibles en r d attaques répétées contre
les ports de la côte méditerranéenne
causé des dégâts énormes à la marine
espagnole
en 1938 l'espagne était devenue le
terrain d'entraînement des choucas les
nouvelles tactiques dassault développé
allait se révéler particulièrement
destructrice quelques années plus tard
pendant ce temps junkers produite une
version plus puissante du moteur humo
désigné modèle de 111 il développe et on
sent chevaux au décollage
il fait monter en 1938 sur une nouvelle
variante du ch tout cas le gie but 87 p
le gain de puissance a totalement changé
le comportement de l'appareil sa
capacité d'emport de charges double à ce
qui lui permettait d'en porter à la fois
un second membre d'équipage et 700 kilos
de bombes une deuxième mitrailleuses
étaient placés dans l'ailé gauche et des
bombes pouvaient désormais être placé
sous la voilure
le système de vision piqué ravey
remplaça l'ancien augmentant ainsi la
précision des largages
afin d'augmenter l'impact psychologique
sur les civils il fait également équipé
d'une sirène activé par la vitesse de
l'air
montée sur l'un des trains principe où
elles généraient un bruit qui restera
gravée dans la mémoire de tous ceux qui
l'ont un jour entendu
la traînée avait été légèrement réduite
en carrés dans le train principal
grâce à son augmentation de puissance sa
vitesse de pointe augmenté de 70
km/heure et celle de piqué de 40
le ministère de l'air était si
impressionné par ces améliorations qu'il
commanda d'emblée 400 machines
junkers augmente à ses cadences de
travail est le premier modèle fut envoyé
dans son unité en 1938 quelques mois
plus tard la luftwaffe demandé 600
appareils supplémentaires
les livraisons se faisait à un bon
rythme et à l'automne 1939 500 chouikha
était pleinement opérationnel
ils étaient divisés en neuf groupes
le gie eu 87 b équiper cinq gruppen de
première ligne alors que les premiers
modèles été retiré du service actif
la plupart d'entre eux furent assignés à
les écoles spéciales les choucas la
gauche trader
dans ces unités on enseignait aux
nouveaux pilotes les techniques de
bombardements en piqué développé en
espagne
il fallait un certain niveau pour
pouvoir y accéder car la moindre erreur
de jugement lors d'une passe en piqué
pouvait être fatale
les équipages de gym 87 connurent leur
première perte lors d'une démonstration
hanoi amr en août 1939
le mauvais temps caché le relief est
très appareils de chtouka gâche vador 76
s'écrasait au sol
deux semaines plus tard les choucas
appuyer l'offensive terrestre contre la
pologne
la luftwaffe ayant la maîtrise totale de
l'espace aérien les choucas peuvent
opérer dans des conditions idéales
les neuf groupes participer aux assauts
3 au nord six au sud
en plus de leur mission d'appui il était
en charge du bombardement d'objectifs
stratégiques comme des terrains
d'aviation des chemins de fer des
navires et des centres de communication
la campagne commence à à l'aube du 1er
septembre
le blitz durera quatre semaines pendant
lesquelles les choucas prouvèrent leur
puissance dévastatrice
il
le rôle principal de la luftwaffe était
d'établir la supériorité aérienne en
détruisant le plus grand nombre possible
l'avion polonais sans leur laisser le
temps de décoller
les rares appareils totalement obsolète
arrivant à éviter les bombardements
n'avait que peu de chances de survie
face aux nazis
à la fin du premier jour la pologne
avait perdu la moitié de sa flotte
aérienne alors que l'envahisseur ne
déplorait que 14 avions montant
la pologne restant sans moyens de
défense la luftwaffe maîtrisait
totalement son espace aérien
désormais libre de tout leur mouvement
les choucas pouvait passer à l'action
semant la mort et la terreur
il transformait en poussière
d'innombrables d'objectifs militaires
coulant la quasi totalité de la flotte
polonaise mais aussi civiles en
participant au pilonnage de varsovie
à la fin du mois de septembre la pologne
capitule
le choucas venait de prouver sa
redoutable efficacité
les unités de bombardements en piqué ne
déplorant la perte que de 30 appareils
venait de jouer un rôle essentiel dans
la première étape dans l'avancée de
l'allemagne nazie
leur production augmentant de façon
exponentielle l'allemagne était
désormais en mesure de fournir ces
appareils à ces pays alliés
l'italie la roumanie et la bulgarie
recevait bientôt ses premiers j'ai eu 87
et le japon commencent à s'y intéresser
au printemps 1940 la luftwaffe créé le
dixième gruppen et 700 appareils
supplémentaires furent mobilisés
la moitié d'entre eux étaient destinés à
l'invasion de la france
mais en avril une nouvelle version au
rayon d'action augmenté pris part à
l'invasion du danemark et de la norvège
le gie ou 87 air était capable de
franchir une distance de 15 100 km
les modifications apportées à sa
structure lui permettait de transporter
150 litres de carburant supplémentaire
sous chaque aile
deux réservoirs largable de 300 litres
chacun était également monté sous les
ailes il était fixé à la place des
montants dans port de charge qui pouvait
rapidement retrouvé leurs fonctions
d'origine pour des missions nécessitant
à plus faible rayon d'action
le 7 avril les troupes nazies débarque à
copenhague bergen narvik et trondheim
par la mer
parallèlement la luftwaffe effectuer ces
parachutages et ses bombardements à
l'aide de plus d'un millier d'appareils
l'armée danoise était bien trop petite
pour opposer une quelconque résistance à
la puissance nazis sa seule option était
la reddition immédiate
mais la norvège résista et se jouant
rapidement à la force alliée né en
angleterre
en une semaine l'armée d'hitler avait à
faire face à des milliers de soldats
britanniques français et à la défense
norvégienne
la plupart des terrains d'aviation
norvégien était tombée aux mains des
parachutistes nazim la luftwaffe gagnait
une nouvelle fois la supériorité
aérienne et avait le champ libre pour
appliquer la même tactique qu'en pologne
les unités chtouka du stg1 étaient
affectés aux bombardements big et de
centre de communications et de
concentration de troupes
ils attaquèrent les navires alliés et
couleurs un bon nombre de destroyers
britanniques et français
sans le soutien de base aérienne et à
cause d'un manque évident de moyens de
défense antiaérienne les alliés se
trouvait dans une situation désespérée
la résistance durant encore quelques
semaines mais aux premiers jours de mai
les troupes alliés réunis dans le sud de
la norvège commencèrent à battre en
retraite
quelques jours plus tard le 10 mai
hitler lança une nouvelle offensive
alors que les colonnes de panzers
commencent leur progression vers les
pays de l'ouest de l'europe des milliers
d'appareils s'attaque au terrain
d'aviation de belgique de france et de
hollande
neuf unités chtouka participèrent aux
assauts couvrant les colonnes de blindés
avec plus de 350 appareils en l'air
en trois jours la majeure partie des
forces aériennes hollandais et belges
avaient été réduites à néant sans même
avoir le temps de décoller
loin de toute menace aérienne les
troupes au sol pouvait progresser sans
entraves et les parachutistes pouvait
opérer librement sur des sites
stratégiques
en hollande les choucas pilonnèrent
rotterdam tuant des centaines de civils
et détruisant des milliers de bâtiments
comme les polonais les hollandais leur
armement vieillissant ne pouvaient tenir
tête à la machine de guerre nazie
surpuissante
en cinq jours la victoire était certaine
le 14 mai les nazis demandait la totale
reddition de rotterdam
devant l'hésitation de l'ennemi une
frappe aérienne massive était organisée
contre la ville portuaire
à la vue d'un ciel parsemé de bombardier
rotterdam déposer les armes
malheureusement cette information n'a pu
être transmise à temps aux pilotes des
bombardiers et une grande partie de la
ville fut rasée
il
le jour suivant la hollande capitulait
la progression vers la belgique n'était
désormais plus entravé et la france
approché inexorablement de son sort
les blindés de goût derrion attaquèrent
par les ardennes et traversèrent la
meuse à la hauteur de sedan
il
la ligne maginot avait été contournée et
la majorité des troupes alliées se
frotter à rebelles à la frontière belge
la voie vers la manche était ouverte
l' attaque massive des panzers avait
permis l'ouverture d'une voie à travers
la france pendant ce temps les choucas
jouer à nouveau le rôle de destruction
massive et de guerre psychologique
une fois encore les conditions étaient
idéales pour eux la luftwaffe avait
d'ores et déjà gagné la supériorité
aérienne grâce au déploiement de plus
d'un millier de bf 109
l'armée de l'air française ne pouvait
tout simplement pas tenir tête à une
telle projection de puissance militaire
seul le dewoitine des 520 était capable
d'affronter un bf 109 mais il était en
sous-nombre évident
on
en moins d'une semaine la france avait
perdu les trois quarts de sa flotte de
chasseurs
en anticipation de la tacc nazis la
royal air force avaient envoyé 14
escadron vers la france
mais il restait désespérément en
sous-nombre la plupart des unités
étaient équipés de bristol benaïm ou de
ferrer battle deux appareils rendu
totalement obsolète par la puissance
nazis
durant les premiers jours de l'invasion
là et rêve devait perdre 75 battles et
86 blenheim
seuls les quatre unités de riz keynes
pouvait infliger des pertes au sein des
nuées de chtouka est de messerschmidt
pilonnant la france
en une seule journée les nazis devait
déplorer la perte de 50 j'ai eu 87
la moitié furent détruits par la défense
antiaérienne et au moins 21 par les week
ends
pour la première fois le point faible du
jeu tout cas été mis au jour
c'était une machine redoutable tant que
la luftwaffe détenait la supériorité
aérienne mais face à un chasseur et demi
il n'avait quasiment aucune chance
le 14 mai cinq jeux tout cas furent
détruits par une formation de week-ends
au cours du même engagement
le 28 mai l'armée belge dépose
finalement les armes et les restes les
troupes françaises et britanniques sont
acculés à dunkerque
un périmètre défensif était organisée et
durant les jours qui suivirent un ballet
incessant de bateaux de toutes tailles
et de tous genres évacua les troupes
alliées de cette souricière
afin d'enrayer cette fuite la luftwaffe
envoyé à tous ses avions disponibles à
la table du convoi
pendant que les troupes au sol progressé
vers l'intérieur de la ville les choucas
attaque est au rassemblement de soldats
dans les ports et le long des plages
la flotte alliée improvisé essuyé de
nombreux raids et trois destroyers et
deux gros transporteurs furent couler
l'un d'eux était un bateau courrier
irlandais le scotia chargé de plus de
2000 soldats il fut touché trois fois
juste à la sortie du port deux bons
frappeurs le pont principal est la
troisième traversa la coque est coulé le
bateau faisant 300 victimes
malgré leur efficacité face à des
objectifs au sol les choucas avait à en
découdre avec la chasse britanniques les
spitfire et les week ends se relayant
depuis leur base du sud de l'angleterre
ont causé de nombreuses pertes au sein
des formations de bombardements piqué
le 5 juin les 900 navire de sauvetage
avait réussi à extraire plus de trois
cent mille soldats alliés et la
luftwaffe avait perdu plus de 200
appareils au-dessus de la région de
dunkerque
dans le reste de la france la bataille
durera encore deux semaines
oui
le 14 juin les nazis foulé le sol de
paris le 16 le gouvernement ne vit plus
d'issue possible
six jours plus tard la france capitulait
la luftwaffe prenait le contrôle de tous
les terrains d'aviation du nord du pays
hitler visé maintenant l'angleterre
afin de préparer une invasion facile les
préparatifs de la destruction de la rfm
furent organisées
la luftwaffe se réorganisent à et de
flop proposition de façon à pouvoir
frapper directement l'angleterre la
flotte numéro trois commandés par le
maréchal perle était basé le long de la
manche
la numéro deux sous les ordres du
maréchal kesselring étaient stationnés
en belgique et aux pays bas
une troisième flotte plus petit prenez
position au danemark et en norvège
à elles trois elles pouvait mobiliser
près de 3000 appareils
elle comptait des avions de
reconnaissance
1260 bombardier longue portée on sent
chasseur monoplace et 320 bombardiers en
piqué
salut
les unités chtouka étaient répartis au
plus près des objectifs
la plupart étaient affectés à la flotte
numéro trois et une partie de la joue
gauche fadeur 1 fut assigné à la flotte
numéro 2
face à elles les britanniques et
n'aligner que 700 spitfire et le week
end
avec cette supériorité numérique et une
plus grande expérience du combat la
victoire de la luftwaffe semblait
assurée d'avancé
l'offensive commence à début juillet par
des reds isolés contre les convois et
les installations portuaires de la côte
de la manche
escortés de bf 109 les choucas bombarder
leurs objectifs aux moyens de charges à
percussion de 500 kg
je
la plupart de ces opérations étaient
gênées par le mauvais temps mais le 25
juillet un grand coup fut portée
les choucas traversèrent la manche par
vagues successives et bombardier un
important convoi au large de douvres
assisté par les eu beau tu es les
couleurs huit bâtiments sur 21
quatre jours plus tard une autre vague
de 50 chtouka escorté de 80 bf 109
lançait un second raid sur douvres
un destroyer est écoulé mais cette fois
4 juillet 87 avait été abattue contre un
seul appareil britannique
le 8 août la luftwaffe lancé sa plus
grande campagne anti maritime
57 chtouka et 50 bf 109 s'attaquer à un
convoi de 20 bâtiments en trois vagues
successives
mais face à un peu plus de trente
spitfire et week-ends 8 chtouka furent
abattus et un grand nombre sérieusement
endommagé
une fois encore sans la couverture de la
maîtrise de l'espace aérien ils avaient
montré leur talon d'achille
le 13 août dans l'après midi goering
lance sa grande offensive contre les
bases aériennes de la ras
thanks to cas furent abattus par les
chasseurs du squadron 609 durant le raid
sur middle wallop
trois jours plus tard ne faut traiter
détruit et un grand nombre sévèrement
atteints alors qu'ils tentaient
d'attaquer tant que maire
l'histoire se répéta le 18 août quand
110 bombardiers en piqué furent envoyés
pour détruire la station radar de
polling et les bases de ford go sport tu
es tu en es island
des raids qui s'avèreront désastreux
pour la troisième flotte de la luftwaffe
30 ch tout cas avaient été soit détruits
soit sévèrement endommagé le stg 77 à
lui seul devait perdre 12 appareils et 6
revint à la base quasiment irréparable
ces derniers combats allaient signer la
démobilisation des choucas du fonds
britannique
le 19 août tous les juifs 87 de la
deuxième et de la troisième flotte était
rappelé
à la fin de l'année la luftwaffe devait
admettre que tout c'est tentative avait
échoué et il fallait trouver un autre
moyen pour conquérir l'angleterre
en 1941 le choucas de schrader
implantait une nouvelle base
les opérations de destruction massive
reprirent dans les espaces aériens
dominée par la loutre face
en janvier les choucas bombardèrent
l'île de malte infligeant de sérieux
dégâts aux porte avions britannique hms
illustrious écoulant un croiseur le
phising tonnes
entre avril et juin ils jouèrent un rôle
important lors des raids sur la grèce la
yougoslavie et la crète
on
comment
pour
quelques destroyer britannique et un
autre croiseur le hms gloucester furent
coulé au large de la crète pendant la
bataille
le 22 juin au matin hitler lançant
l'opération barberousse l'invasion de
l'urss
comme toujours les choucas ont constitué
le fer de lance
après une série de raids parfaitement
synchronisé la plupart de la force
aérienne soviétique était réduite à
néant
à la fin du mois il avait perdu 4000
appareils contre seulement 200 côté
nazis
les troupes au sol progresser rapidement
les russes pris par surprise par la
coordination des assauts bâtir en
retraite
une fois encore la luftwaffe gagnait la
supériorité aérienne les choucas pouvait
commencer leur travail de soutien
tactique bombardant les sites
stratégiques pour ouvrir la voie aux
colonnes de blindés
la puissance nazis progressait
inexorablement vers l'intérieur de la
russie
de très nombreux soldats soviétiques
furent capturés et une quantité
impressionnante d'armes et le véhicule
fut récupérée est détruit
les pertes enregistrées par la luftwaffe
en comparaison à celles subies par les
soviétiques étaient dérisoires mais
l'intensité et la longueur des combats
allaient commencer à faire tourner le
vent
toutes les forces étant projeté en
première ligne l'approvisionnement en
pièces détachées été lents et
inefficaces
la défaite allait être cuisant les puis
danses d'automne transformer nos
terrains en amas de boue empêchant la
progression des bataillons de logistique
la première ligne ne fonctionnait plus
qu'à 50 % de son potentiel incapables de
recevoir le soutien et le renfort
matériel qu'elle attendait
la température commençait à chuter
alors que le froid s'installait les
troupes au sol arriver tant bien que mal
à se mettre en place pour l'assaut final
sur moscou
mais la température continué de chuter
l'armée nazie n'était pas préparé à
faire face à de telles conditions
climatiques
jour après jour la situation s'aggravait
la température négative gelé les moteurs
et paralyser les véhicules un problème
auquel les nazis n'ont su faire face
la grande armée nazie était paralysée et
le franc au portel soldats alain
une fois encore un point faible la
structure militaire d'hitler été révélé
cette fois impossible d'organiser un
blitz comme il le faisait auparavant
malgré le climat et les attaques
incessantes de l'armée rouge les nazis
tarbes ont jusqu'au printemps
fin 1941 un nouveau modèle de chtouka
allait remplacer le gie eu 87 p
avec une envergure plus large et un
moteur plus puissant il était capable
d'en porter des charges allant jusqu'à
une tonne 8
le blindage avait été perfectionné et
une double mitrailleuse remplaçait la 7
mm 9 à l'arrière du cockpit
surnommé le dorat il fait la base de
nombreux dérivés pour les trois années à
venir ce fut la version du ch tout cas
la plus produite à
plus de 3000 exemplaires sortir des
usines soit la moitié de la production
totale du j80 seb
la dernière version produite fut le gie
ou 87 g
spécifiquement conçu pour la lutte anti
char c'est aérofreins peut retirer et
deux canons de prendre 7 mm pu remonter
sous les ailes
bien qu'il fût plus lourd et moins
maniable sa puissance de feu était
considérable et il était capable à lui
seul de détruire un char soviétique
après une période d'essai d'armements
arrêt chine le gustave entrée en service
en 1943 juste à temps pour participer à
la bataille de koursk
des unités anti chars avaient été
spécialement thé et les pertes infligées
aux colonnes blindées russe sur sévère
en afrique une version modifiée de
chtouka servait dans l'africa corp sous
les ordres de rebelles depuis 1942
équipé de réservoirs plus vaste et de
filtres anti poussière ils participèrent
à la plupart des opérations dont l'
attaque de tobrouk et la bataille d'el
alamein
alors que l'armée britannique lançait sa
contre-offensive en 1943 les dégâts
infligés aux unités chtouka furent
considérables
à la fin du mois de mai les pertes
avaient été si sévère que tous les jeux
tout cas restants furent démobilisés du
front africain
malgré de nombreuses modifications
apportées le gym 87 devenait de plus en
plus vulnérables
face à l'aviation alliée il devenait
obsolète
mais jusqu'à ce que le faux que woolf
190 sortent des usines la luftwaffe
continuer malgré tout à envoyer sexe
tout cas au front
et
en 1944 les alliés débarquaient radio en
italie et firent face à une résistance
acharnée
les choucas pilonné hommes et véhicules
forçant les alliés à revoir leurs
stratégies d'intervention
cette tentative de débarquement avait
été un échec mais ils n'avaient pas dit
leur dernier mot
cette bataille brève fut l'un des
derniers faits de guerre des choucas
20 44 la quasi-totalité des choucas
schwaller avait opté pour les f w190
enfin disponible
dans un élan de réorganisation de la
dernière chance la luftwaffe revoyait
entièrement ses stratégies
moins de 300 ch tout cas était encore
opérationnelles étaient en général
relégué au raid nocturne
en septembre après avoir produit 5700
exemplaires les chaînes cessèrent de le
produire
même si quelques unités allait continuer
à l'exploiter jusqu'à la fin de la
guerre le jus 87 devenait totalement
dépassé
au fur et à mesure de la progression de
la guerre les pilotes de chtouka toute
notion d'appartenance à un camp
particulier mis à part avait fait preuve
de plus en plus de bravoure pour
s'acquitter de leur mission hans ulrich
roudel était l'un de ses pilotes le plus
décoré de la seconde guerre mondiale
surnommé l'aigle de l'est il commandait
les mâles match to kage schrader et fut
le seul militaire à recevoir la plus
haute distinction de l'armée allemande
pour acte de bravoure
en ayant participé à 3500 mission il
restera l'un des aviateurs ayant connu
le plus grand pourcentage de victoires
de l'histoire
la plupart de ces victoire avait été
remportée face à des troupes au sol en
volant à basse altitude sous un feu
défensif nourris il détruit 519 chars
soviétiques dont 17 le même jour
goodell a totalisé à lui seul un
croiseur un destroyer un cuirassé 70
avions au sol et on s'envole plus des
centaines de véhicules de pièces
d'artillerie de colonnes de blindés et
de convois terrestres et maritimes sans
compter les installations et les ponts
il a sauvé 12 compagnons d'armé six
équipages de chtouka de la capture
en essayant de se courir un autre
appareil écrasé sur le territoire
soviétique en 1944 il fut capturé et
emprisonné il s'échappa malgré une
blessure par balle à l'épaule et
parcouru 50 km à travers les lignes
ennemies avant d'atteindre la frontière
allemande
son avion fut touché 30 fois plus
qu'aucun autre encore en état de voler
et lui même fut blessé cinq fois dont
une fois sérieusement à la jambe
ont dû l'amputer d'une partie de la
jambe mais six semaines plus tard à
l'encontre de ses ordres il reprend les
commandes de son avion et continue à
servir jusqu'à la fin de la guerre
sa devise était seule la bombe ont
conduit à la perte
le coup infligé à l'effort de guerre par
cet homme se compte en milliards de
francs
aux commandes de son jeu tout cas hans
ulrich roudel restera sans doute l'un
des plus grands pilotes de combat de
tous les temps
mais